l'étranger en commençant par la somalie
la situation est toujours extrêmement
tendue sur place après l'embuscade de
samedi dernier qui a coûté la vie je
vous le rappelle à 23 casques bleus
l'onu qui s'apprête à attaquer les
responsables craint des représailles
elle a donc demandé aux organisations
humanitaires de quitter le pays
incessamment l'organisation care est
déjà parti hier ce matin là icf l'action
internationale contre la faim annonce
qu'elle lui emboîte le pas pour des
raisons de sécurité depuis hier soir des
tracts hostiles aux forces des nations
unies sont distribués dans la capitale
philippe rochot jean louis normandin sur
cette route de mogadiscio à buy de rats
les véhicules des organisations
humanitaires sont régulièrement la cible
des bandes armées s'ils ne sont pas
exportés par les militaires de l'onu
malgré cela l'action internationale
contre la faim avait décidé de rester
comme ici dans le village de bora cabba
mais depuis l'embuscade qui a fait 30
morts chez les casques bleus pakistanais
à mogadiscio la lcf a décidé de
suspendre sa mission en somalie
tout comme médecins sans frontières ou
pharmaciens sans frontières tous
redoutent que le personnel ne subisse
des représailles car les soldats de
l'onu serait sur le point de frapper les
responsables de l'embuscade de samedi
pour l'heure faute qui cherche au fait
c'est piller les voitures volées même
les voitures est fait pour ça
vingt-et-une personnes de l'action
internationale contre la faim vont donc
quitter le pays alors qu'elles ont
nourri pendant des mois des milliers
d'enfants soignés des centaines de
malades
avec leurs deux médecins et leurs six
infirmières son action touché près de
80000 personnes
le départ de plusieurs organisations
humanitaires de ce mal y laisse la
population confrontée à de nouveaux
problèmes d' aide alimentaire et
médicale
ce sont uniquement les dix huit soldats
de l'onu qui serait à présent en mesure
de distribuer cette nourriture dont les
somaliens ont encore fortement besoin
les organisations humanitaires avaient
jusqu'à 14 heures pour quitter le pays
bon